you do you feel like having a high body
count as a girl has consequences
um I think it does
um I I think it does and like even from
experience I think that's it some guys
about this turns me off but then I'm
like okay then you're you're yeah for me
it's compatibility
I think compatibility is so important so
would you tell a young woman to sleep
around and like explore their sexuality
or would you tell them to keep your body
count as low as possible so you can get
the best quality husband
um I would say what what is important to
you and some people that's it some
people some people sleep around for
validation and they'd be like don't do
that right don't do that like please
like don't do that like I have had
casual sex because I enjoy sex that's
that's the right long and short of it I
enjoy sex
um female sexual Liberation I'm all here
for it yeah um but I used to be very
codependent because it was all dependent
upon my self-worth was dependent upon
being desirable to a man and I got to a
point in like late 2020 where I was like
I don't want to do that anymore because
I've either been undervalued or
underappreciated and I ended up in
relationships where I thought the men
were my league but they didn't respect
me so then I dated men who were under my
league who adored me and then I was like
you're not enough well do you yeah do
you think maybe they were actually your
league because like you can't say that
someone was your league if they weren't
able to commit to you like your league
is who you can get to commit to you but
then this comes to the success and
ambition and blah blah blah right but
remember men and women are valued for
different things yeah so so I settled
for men that were short and broke I
settle for men but they could say like
they settled for you with a high body
count but they could they could say the
same thing but they are men that
literally the men that I settled for
were men that literally were like they
look at me in the morning and be like
beautiful person in the world and I was
like no I'm not you're incorrect I you I
was like you literally you expect too
too little
Behavior
Behavior yeah like I was gonna say I
think there is a I think there is a
middle yeah between
um between
uh a girl getting a guy because I get
what you're saying yeah like for for
girls your league isn't who you can
sleep with your league is who you can
get to commit who can get to commit to
you but what I would say is that a lot
of girls date guys who could have
committed to them but because they've
dated them in a certain way they've put
themselves in the friends with benefit
zone so now that's not on the table does
that make sense so I think there is like
you know oh for sure like there is like
a you know like oh if a guy is a nine
and he's sleeping with a girl who's
quote and quite a five that she's
probably never gonna commit to her right
but it's possible that okay for guys in
eight who gets a lot of attention he may
sleep with a girl as an A but if she
plays it wrong you might think oh she's
hot
like she's very attractive I think that
she's not girlfriend I think guys go
down and looks all the time I'm not like
just sex yeah I'm not discounting that
but I'm saying like as a girl it's still
what you can get to commit because
that's still you it's your it's your
choices yeah right it's true but I think
I think girls don't um
I think a lot of girls
due date guys who could have committed
to them it's just the way because the
way they dated him the guy was like well
she's not girlfriend material yeah and
then this does come back to body count
because I've had an experience where
recently a guy is like well I've not
dated anyone since you I get a bit
jealous when you tell me you want to end
things and I'm like but you've told me
you're not going to commit to me you're
not gonna be serious about me I'm never
gonna be your girlfriend I'm like but
you are serious about me and to be fair
body count doesn't actually relate to
our situation but oh there's just so
many like really like intricate details
and it's not it's not necessarily like
practical in this day and age right
because again the average age of first
marriage is 27 like guys used to marry
virgins and now like guys don't even
like want virgins yeah but that's it
it's that whole so it's all black and
white situation where a guy you know a
lot of it's about ego and a lot of it a
lot of it is about people's self-worth
and self-esteem and oh I did have a
really good point to say and it's about
attractiveness even that so I used to go
off of the ethos to a blind person we
got it the same so I gave a lot of
people chances and I used to go on dates
with anyone because I just don't do that
I'm like don't don't do it this sounds
so awful but like so I did that I was
like talking to give them pity sex like
I used to pick it I didn't say that I
used to pick not I used to pity kiss
people I give people my phone number and
be like I don't really want to give you
my phone but maybe if you're showing me
interest and they're going so this is
what I say undervalued or underwhelmed
yeah so that was what I ended up in I
used to be like
guys that I thought were like my level
my league would like not value me
and then guys that were who really
adored me like loved me really valued me
I was like oh you're underwhelming I
don't think like you match up and that's
why I've been single single by choice
for a year and a half because I'm like I
don't want to get hurt I I don't want to
hurt anyone but I don't get hurt and I
was like I'm actually we're also you're
gonna be like being alone you're also
competing for a small percentage of guys
too that you're probably attracted yeah
you know that only like 10 I don't even
I don't know the exact stat but I've
heard numbers from five to fifteen
percent of dating app swipes or I don't
use dating apps
no and it's because dating apps do tend
to be a black and white party in that
you've either got people on there who
are like I just want something casual
nice not nothing serious
um or you've got people who are like I'm
looking for a relationship so you've got
two types of processing you've got top
down or bottom up top down processing
and people who are like I want a
relationship Ergo I am looking for
someone who can fill that criteria so
when they go on dates when they swipe
they're like I'm literally thinking
about are you going through your
relationship with material or
there's people like me I'm bottom up
where I'm like I'd rather just meet
someone and be like where is this gonna
go let's live in the now let's take it
day by day time by time women it would
be better for women if we dated more
intentionally because to me it's like if
you could be single you could be single
let's say you're single for five years
you're in a relationship for five years
like I would think that the girl would
probably be less like
heartbroken and have less trauma if she
was in a relationship for five years
because I mean Assuming he's not
narcissist assuming there's no abuse
narcissists like any of that stuff
because if you're just like dating
around like like I don't know like at
some point you're gonna get rejected by
guys that like don't call you back or
like like you know what I'm saying like
[ __ ] like that happens all the time
investor is subjective like Eat Pray
Love is based on a real life story where
she's she's married she's successful
she's like I'm actually not happy I'm
actually not like to Circle back with
that lady yeah
yeah and it's like that was it there are
there are people who sometimes wake up
and go [ __ ] I'm not happy and I should
be happy I hate the concept of should
and so I'm I'm a really big advocate for
like difference do you think happiness
like comes and goes oh yeah like like do
you think you should just leave a
relation a relationship with like kids
and stuff if you're not happy so I was
gonna I was gonna say would you here's a
question would you sacrifice happiness
for fulfillment
yeah
would you because I think happened like
you say happiness can go up and down
yeah like it's an emotion right it comes
it's not happiness isn't a
permanent state that you can be in but
you can be content and fulfilled what
you have but would you sacrifice
happiness for fulfillment
but then it depends like for me
happiness
is probably
oh no to be fair happiness isn't
dependent upon fulfillment but I'm
always over there like we could die
tomorrow as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible